all right i got another video for you
guys
showing you guys how to program a new
key
um in my bmw
this is uh
bmw um 335i this will work for the older
model bmws i think it's like
2007 and six and up
and a couple other models the ones that
use this key um
so basically i'm gonna program this key
in as you can see i'm gonna put it in
the slot
and it's going to show that it's not
programmed
okay so put this one to the side this is
what i'm going to be programming in this
is the one that does work this is the
factory key
as you can see when i put it in there
it comes on the dash comes on
all right let me turn the light back on
it turned on okay
all right so now i'm going to show you
guys the process um this is connected to
the internet it has to be connected to
the internet to the hotspot on my phone
so basically um i have the hot spot on
my phone so you go to that you go to bmw
and this is the xp 400 so i'm going to
be using this tool back automatic
selection didn't work for some reason i
don't know so i'm going to go to smart
selection
so with smart selection is going to
automatically
scan the system
okay
pulled up everything
it's a cast three plus
just adding a key
okay so now let's say it's reading
around it takes about a minute
okay remove the remove the key from the
ignition
so there's a swatch you please take the
key and please be sure the upright is
required otherwise this may take the
vehicle maybe make the vehicle abnormal
it is a vehicle to read out the
information please try and clear the dtc
make back the normal status okay so
there's no key ignition
so uh
like i said it's the factory key
this is the new one it's a semi smart
key
okay so let's connect them to the
internet again
yes i'm backing up the original key data
this is in case it goes corrupt
so i saved it
backed it up
so the knees are showing all the keys
slots that are available
okay
so i want to put in a nine
it's available
so the cast part number version needs a
working key to learn
please connect the device to program put
the working key into the program so i'm
going to take the working key
and put it in the slot in the programmer
okay
then i'm going to hit ok
so now let's read in the keys
information
this will start blinking
it's reading the keys data
okay
so the key information was right
successfully please proceed to the next
step
okay so you press okay
okay so it's a semi smart key because it
goes into the slot here
okay please connect the device program
and put the new key in the programmer so
i got to take this key out
and
put the new key in
[Music]
this is the new key
that i'm going to be putting in
so i'll put it head down first
into the programmer
and then press ok
this key needs to be pre-processed okay
so pre-process it
that's what it's doing now
it's blinking
it's processing the key please wait
keep processing is successful
okay so i press okay
now it's writing the key it's making the
key right now
[Music]
succeeding generating the okay please
insert the key into the ignition and
switch to start the car
okay so i'll take this out put in the
slot
hit the brake
and start the car
it's good to go
and the light went off on the dash
see now it's enabled
and good to go
second key
with the new one
now i have a new key
and it'll
and when you program the key it programs
uh the lock and unlock buttons and
everything so i'm gonna show you guys
that that's what it's gonna blink when i
hit the unlock
lock here the doors lock
unlock
lock unlock
and then the trunk plot works too
whatever and i just got to cut the
emergency key and that's about it good
to go got a second key if you guys have
any questions feel free to ask them to
like share subscribe and comment peace
that's how you make a bmw key